chosen tarnished and would be lord
descend into the depths far below the
earth tree capital
seek audience with the three fingers and
the flame of frenzy
if you inherit the flame of frenzy
your flesh
will serve as kindling
and the girl
can be spared
setting you on the righteous path of
lordship
the path of the lord of chaos
burn the ur tree
to the ground
and incinerate
all that divides and
distinguishes oh
may chaos take
the world
may chaos
take
the world
so says shabriri the slanderer one of
the three main endings of eldon ring is
the lord of frenzied flame this is
something i've discussed on my channel a
few times in my endings video and in
relation to a discussion on the
primordial crucible and while i
unquestionably view it as the worst
ending in the context of the in-game
world it is one of the philosophically
richest and most interesting endings for
a quick recap this ending has the player
become the lord of chaos and end the
world by melting everything away with
the flame of frenzy also called the
yellow chaos flame the three fingers and
their patron outer god the frenzied
flame see individuated life as a curse
believing that the suffering of
subjective experience is so terrible
that life simply isn't worth living
originally life was one big blob some
kind of continuous being in the one
great or the primordial crucible and the
frenzied flame would have us go back to
that kind of singularity where
individual experience is impossible we
learn more about this reasoning from
hayata's dialogue
all that there is came from the one
great
then came fractures
and births
and souls but the greater will made a
mistake
torment
despair
affliction every sin
every curse
every one born of the mistake
and so
what was borrowed
must be returned
melt it all away with the yellow chaos
flame
until all
is won again
those who gave me grace
howled without words
saying they wish they were never born
they come their lord
take their torment
despair their affliction
every sin every curse
and melt it all away
this lord of chaos
no more fractures
no more birth
this view of complete denial of life can
be roughly categorized as a kind of
nihilism a rejection of meaning or more
accurately as pessimism or anti-natalism
consisting in the belief that life is
not worth living or continuing due to
its unjustified suffering and pain
another lore youtuber ratatoskr actually
has a really good video on the frenzied
flame and this view where he does a
great job of not only making the lore
understandable but also in relaying the
feeling of the pessimistic viewpoint he
does this by reading a selection of
timeless russian literature by the
author fyodor dostoevsky he also has
another video going through a lot of the
specifics of the actual in-game lore so
i figured i can leave that be for now
in this video i want to follow
ratatoskr's lead and try to relate a
certain feeling and some arguments that
revolve around the flame of frenzy and
its ending but instead of capturing the
viewpoint of the frenzied flame i want
to present the other side of things the
view that the end of all life as we know
it is actually a bad thing to do this i
will look at what melano has to say on
the matter and i will be reading some
literature of my own from an author who
has also read and appreciated
dostoyevsky someone who is upfront about
the suffering and cruelty of life but
nonetheless concluded that our only
worthwhile option is to affirm and say
yes to life i'm going to be reading
excerpts from the 19th century author
and philosopher frederick nietzsche in
the first book he ever published the
birth of tragedy nietzsche shows us that
he understands the view of the frenzied
flame he does this by recalling a folk
story of the ancient greeks a story
whose dialogue would be eerily at home
in elden ring coming out of the mouth of
the three fingers or hayata rather he
says
there is an ancient story that king
might has hunted in the forest a long
time for the wise silliness the
companion of dionysus without capturing
him when silliness at last fell into his
hands the king asked what was the best
and most desirable of all things for man
fixed and immovable the demigod said not
a word till at last urged by the king he
gave a shrill laugh and broke out into
these words
oh wretched ephemeral race children of
chance and misery why do you compel me
to tell you what it would be most
expedient for you not to hear
what is best of all is utterly beyond
your reach not to be born not to be
to be nothing but the second best for
you is this
to die soon
the words of silliness are essentially
the same as we hear from the frenzied
flame a doctrine against life going back
over 2000 years
nietzsche continues discussing the
greeks and their myths especially of the
gods apollo and dionysus in more texts
that bears near identity to what we hear
in game niche considers that the
properly dionysian suffering is like a
transformation into air water earth and
fire
and that we are therefore to regard the
state of individuation as the origin and
primal cause of all suffering as
something objectionable in itself
the individuation that the frenzied
flame lamented is precisely the topic
here it sounds like fromsoft or miyazaki
might have read some nietzsche he
continues this view of things already
provides us with all the elements of a
profound and pessimistic view of the
world together with the mystery doctrine
of tragedy the fundamental knowledge of
the oneness of everything existent the
conception of individuation as the
primal cause of evil and of art as the
joyous hope that the spell of
individuation may be broken in augury of
a restored oneness
nietzsche saw certain kinds of art such
as the tragic plays of the ancient
greeks as being able to bring about a
feeling of oneness which transcends the
pains of life the flame of frenzy
desires to return to the oneness of the
primordial crucible and in order to do
this it desires an end of individuated
life but nietzsche says that art and
aesthetic experience have the power to
bring about that feeling in life
eliminating the need for our collective
annihilation
the metaphysical comfort with which i am
suggesting even now every true tragedy
leaves us that life is at the bottom of
things despite all the changes of
appearances indestructibly powerful and
pleasurable this comfort appears in
incarnate clarity in the course of the
seders the seders are an aspect of greek
myth and a core part of tragic greek
plays a chorus of natural beings who
live in erratically as it were behind
all civilization and remain eternally
the same despite the changes of
generations and of the history of
nations with this chorus the deep-minded
helene or greek who is so singularly
qualified for the most delicate and
severe suffering consoles himself
he who has glanced with piercing eye
into the very heart of the terrible
destructive processes of so-called
universal history as also into the
cruelty of nature and is in danger of
longing for a buddhistic negation of the
will
art saves him and through art life saves
him or herself
nietzsche concludes this section and
point by referencing shakespeare's
hamlet who at the pinnacle of his own
tragedy contemplated suicide and the
value of life in the now infamous phrase
to be or not to be
that is the question
to this question of suicide nietzsche
writes
true knowledge an insight into the
horrible truth outweighs any motive for
action both in hamlet and in the
dionysian man
no comfort avails anymore longing
transcends a world after death even the
gods
existence is negated along with its
glittering reflection in the gods or in
an immortal beyond conscious of the
truth he has once seen man now sees
everywhere only the horror or absurdity
of existence
now he understands what is symbolic in
ophelia's fate now he understands the
wisdom of the sylvan god silliness he is
nauseated
here when the danger to his will is
greatest art approaches as a saving
sorceress expert at healing she alone
knows how to turn these nauseous
thoughts about the horror or absurdity
of existence into notions with which one
can live
these are the sublime as the artistic
taming of the horrible and the comic as
the artistic discharge of the nausea of
absurdity
when we are frozen in action or in life
by the terrors of existence of the world
the unjustified cruelty and suffering it
is art that can take this and turn it
into something with which we can live it
is art which can give us the feeling the
frenzied flame desires without
annihilating the world
and beyond the saving graces of art
nietzsche had plenty more to say to the
question of the worthiness of life and
the feasibility of total annihilation as
suffering solution we have been reading
from the birth of tragedy which as i
said is nietzsche's first work we can
see another approach to an answer in one
of his final published works twilight of
the idols here nietzsche takes direct
aim at those who would deny life and how
they themselves are unjustified in their
claims of life's lack of justification
he writes once one has comprehended the
outrage of such a revolt against life as
has become almost sacrosanct in
christian morality one has fortunately
also comprehended something else
the futility apparentness absurdity and
mendaciousness of such a revolt
a condemnation of life by the living
remains in the end a mere symptom of a
certain kind of life the question
whether it is justified or unjustified
is not even raised thereby
one would require a position outside of
life and yet have to know it as well as
one as many as all who have lived it in
order to be permitted even to touch the
problem of the value of life reasons
enough to comprehend that this problem
is for us an unapproachable problem when
we speak of values we speak with the
inspiration with the way of looking at
things which is part of life
life itself forces us to posit values
life itself values through us when we
posit values
now maybe the frenzied flame being some
sort of godlike being that we do not
have a clear picture of is in more of a
place to speak on the merits of life
under the one great of unindividuated
light we're all are one and no one
exists independently
but at that we would have to take its
word its word transferred first through
the three fingers and then through
hayeta we ourselves have no standing to
see or claim that life in the frenzied
flame ending would be more valuable than
life as it is or could be we have no
standing to talk about the value of that
which is outside of life for we are in
life and only through life can we value
things can we claim value or lack of
value so to do so about something
outside of life would be unjustified
though in terms of the standing there is
one more we hear from on the matter
one who has suffered burned and
seemingly even died before so they like
the frenzied flame might have standing
to discuss the value of this ending this
is one who has been tormented and likely
despaired but who nevertheless continues
to affirm at the grace near the three
fingers at the bottom of the merchant's
tomb melina speaks to us
she defends life in the same ways we
hear from nietzsche first by affirming
it and then by pointing out how its lack
is categorically impossible to be valued
she says
if you intend to claim the frenzied
flame
i ask that you cease
it is not to be meddled with
it is chaos
devouring life and thought unending
however ruined this world has become
however mired in torment and despair
life endures
births continue
there is beauty in that
is there not
if you would become lord
do not deny this notion
please
leave the frenzied flame alone
i ask you
one more time
please
seek not the frenzied flame
as one who strives to become a lord
deny not the lives
the new births of this world
those who would are not fit to be called
lord
when the land they preside over is
lifeless
please
put a stop to this madness
the lord of frenzied flame is no lord at
all
when the land they preside over is
lifeless
i want to end this video with one more
piece of nietzsche's writings the most
literary and full of feeling of today's
selection it comes from thus spoke
zarathustra nietzsche's masterpiece and
most literary work a narrative he
developed to showcase some of his most
pressing thoughts
in this section the main character
zarathustra has just tried to speak to a
crowd about the need for a new valuation
of life after the death of religion and
its dogma which is something nietzsche
saw in his own time and predicted about
the future that with the decline of
religion we're going to need a new way
to view understand and value in life and
in the world
the crowd zarathustra speaks to does not
understand him so they mock him
in this piece nietzsche expressed his
dismay at a potential kind of future
person who after the end of the reign of
religion seeks the end of suffering a
life of complete peace idleness and
niceness to me i read this as a weaker
form of the followers of the frenzied
flame kind of like a real world analog
motivated by the same ideas but unable
to enact the same end goal of worldwide
genocide due to obvious practical
limitations
pier nietzsche writes
when zarathustra had spoken these words
he beheld the people again and was
silent there they stand he said to his
heart there they laugh they do not
understand me i am not the mouth for
these ears must ones smash their ears
before they learn to listen with their
eyes must one clatter like kettle drums
and preachers of repentance or do they
believe only the stammer
they have something of which they are
proud what do they call that which makes
them proud education they call it it
distinguishes them from goat herds that
is why they do not like to hear the word
contempt applied to them
let me then address their pride let me
speak to them of what is most
contemptible
but that is the last man in the german
nietzsche uses the word mensch which
even though it sounds like man i think
translates better to human being or
human just it's a very general word so
i'm going to be using the last human
beings or the last human and thus spoke
zarathustra to the people the time has
come for man to set himself a goal the
time has come for mankind to plant the
seed of their highest hope their soil is
still rich enough but one day this soil
will be poor and domesticated and no
tall tree will be able to grow in it
alas the time is coming when human
beings will no longer shoot the arrow of
their longing beyond human beings and
the string of their bow will have
forgotten how to work i say unto you one
must still have chaos in oneself to be
able to give birth to a dancing star i
say unto you you still have chaos in
yourselves
alas the time is coming when mankind
will no longer give birth to a star alas
the time of the most despicable human is
coming one that is no longer able to
despise himself
behold i show you the last human being
what is love what is creation what is
longi what is a star thus asks the last
human being and they blink
the earth has become small and on it
hops the last human being who makes
everything small their race is as
inerraticable as the flea beetle the
last human being lives longest
we have invented happiness say the last
human beings and they blink
they have left the regions where it was
hard to live for one needs warmth one
still loves one's neighbor and rubs
against him for one needs warmth
becoming sick and harboring suspicion
are sinful to them one proceeds
carefully a fool whoever still stumbles
over stones or human beings a little
poison now and then that makes for
agreeable dreams and much poison in the
end or an agreeable death
one still works for work is a form of
entertainment but one is careful lest
the entertainment be too harrowing
one no longer becomes poor or rich both
require too much exertion who still
wants to rule who obey both require too
much exertion
no shepherd and one herd everybody wants
the same everybody is the same whoever
feels different goes voluntarily into a
madhouse formerly all the world was mad
say the most refined and they blink
one is clever and knows everything that
has ever happened so there is no end of
derision
one still quarrels but one is soon
reconciled
else it might spoil the digestion one
has one's little pleasure for the day
and one's little pleasure for the night
but one has a regard for health
we have invented happiness say the last
mention
and they blink
you